taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them we're back it's time for taste
buds everybody
t-a-s-t-e buds I'm back here your host
Joe list and uh happy to have my two
very special guests this week we got Sal
volcano and Joe
deroza and South volcano are here and
we're excited I am very happy to be here
it's good to be here man I'm very
excited today
I love having Joe on one because I just
love Joe in general but two is because
Joe genuinely enjoys the show I love the
show yes yeah but you've never and
you're vocal about it you post online
that you say you love the show I see it
all the time very nice I love you I jump
in the comments I love you I love you I
just I like to write the comments but
yeah I haven't watched the full program
absolutely I get that number one I'm not
offended by that I'm just saying I I'm
impressed that you have such love for it
just from the clips and that but I get
it well I have this thing when do you
guys have this at all when I'm home it's
time to watch something I have a lot of
pressure on myself and I'm like I should
be watching a film yeah or a sporting
event yeah yeah so I'm like a podcast
it's not really art I just I bought
three hundred dollars worth of Blu-ray
4K whatever movies well that's that
that's excellent because that is a that
is a flourishing medium
yeah yeah I know you have your jokes
watch what happens when the grid goes
down who's gonna have all the
entertainment at his house you're not
going to be allowed in no but
300.9 is reasonable who are you to judge
me not a week after my birthday I'm not
judging you I just spent 500 on eight
tracks
I'm not judging you 4K what happens when
when the terrestrial radio goes down 4K
you you think you're getting 4k on a
stream
you're getting it you're not getting 4k
on the stream I believe I have no idea
to be honest okay but my point is how
much was each how many DVDs
were they were they used no you put new
yeah wait did you could have brought you
they're not DVDs they're 4K discs
okay that's the latest medium but what
is the disc a fork it's called a 4K UHD
ultra high definition that's what does
it look like it's a disc it looks like a
Blu-ray or DVD but it's it's not a DVD
is a different uh um um
technology excuse me all right well then
I so you're telling me that pushing a
new physical media in this day and age
brother 4K is yeah I know about 4K it's
been around a long time I have 4K
television yeah but but they didn't have
4K discs these are 4K they do 4K full
transfer the movies look unbelievable
okay so you get a 4K you get a 4K of a
movie that came out in the 70s and you
watch it and you're like this is what it
looked like day one in the theater oh
okay okay so Joe who actually Joe is a
filmmaker himself yes I am a filmmaker
shot out there that's correct I just did
a thing with you we just did a little a
program together we did yes I cast you
and I appreciate the director listening
because often times people write like
who should we get for this and I'm like
oh you gotta get scooply Boop and then
they don't even look which is my working
name
are you sure it's not just a DVD will it
play in a PlayStation play or do you
have to buy uh the new ones because the
new ones are 4K compatible but but no it
will not play in a regular Blu-ray
player I mean if it looks like a DVD and
it sounds like a dude wait but DVD looks
like a CD you told me it's the same
thing
okay you know what that's a very good
point Thank you you're calling a 4K do
you say I got a 4K yeah
okay you don't want people to think
you're messing around with like anyway
to answer your question how much is each
one wait wait wait we're gonna guess how
many 4K discs does 300 yield some of
them were box sets to be fair I got some
box sets Okay I'm gonna say a 4K disc is
about 29.99 I I swear to God I was gonna
say thirty dollars okay very similar it
ranges anywhere from now they can be
much cheaper than this if they're on
sale or whatever but the average price
is anywhere from about 25 bucks to up to
including about 50. for single yeah
depending on what the addition is and
like sometimes it's like 50th
Anniversary 4K transfer there's four
versions of the film on this whatever
sometimes those are a little pricier
okay but I got a lot of fun stuff
well one of the things I bought was the
George Romero Dawn of the Dead 4K and
there are four cuts of the film on it
all of them in 4k uh which is usually
it's one cut will be in 4k and then the
others will be on Blu-ray
seems excessive I don't care for myself
Cuts or alternate endings you're
presenting me a story give me the story
here's the only reason I brought it up
not to talk about my problems with
spending money on things because I make
me feel as if I have a family at home
no I I spend the zombies are your
brothers and sisters right I brought it
up because you
've seen a film and what I was trying to
say was I just spent 300 hours because
of that notion where I'm like I should
have I should be with a film right now
and and art and all this stuff I think
with the four different cuts is really
where they get you because they're going
to charge more for those cuts naturally
right but what I wonder if you watch
them if you watch them on four
television at the same time they have
four different cuts they're not four
different movies not four different
stories so at some point each cut
there's an extra scene or two you're
gonna watch all four and notate where
the I may or may what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna start with some of the cuts I
haven't seen because I've seen the
original cut but and I'm gonna see if
it's any different but here's the thing
I'm going to see if it's any different
I'm gonna it better be you just smack
down fifty dollars fine I indulged on
that one because Dawn of the Dead is one
of my favorite horror movies ever and I
only have ever had a used DVD of it I
never upgraded to Blu-ray or two it was
two times yeah and I was like I'm gonna
go for the big okay on this one okay
take us through your other selections I
got a I got a great box set of horror
movies from Mexico two of which I've
definitely wanted to see for a long time
that you were never able to get in the
states okay so that was a cool box set I
got
those Mexican horror box sets come by
here's what yeah I got I got Swamp Thing
and return of Swamp Thing I bet you got
the 4K you got the 4K that's good that's
good so you can so you can see how they
filmed it on the camcorder
though right yeah this [__] it feels it
feels just the swamp is a character in
and of itself in the 4K
I called Pat Walsh Wala I I called
because he collects movies incessantly
as well okay he owns every movie in the
Criterion Collection wow like everyone
he owns everybody know that he owns
every single movie in the criteria
collection wow anyway by keeping the
lights on over there I called him from
Waterloo Waterloo records in Austin and
I go
I go if there was a support group for
like movie collector addict I used to do
it but I stopped I go if there was a
support group I go I just hit my bottom
this is the story I would tell okay I go
I was standing at the counter in
Waterloo records with a line of people
behind me going is there any way you can
tell me
what Burt Reynolds movies you have
between 81 and 89.
that's amazing yeah
from all the action titles you have in
stock and I go Pat I am asking this as I
am holding a 4K copy of both Swamp Thing
in return
and it's like I need to I need help
there's something really wrong
now will you watch all of these DVDs or
do you buy them because you want them
you collect them and then you never put
them in no I watch them I have a backlog
of stuff I haven't gotten to yet but but
but I've seen most of what I own at this
point at my height of my addiction I uh
I had about 600 DVDs I love it I uh many
of them though I'd say at least half of
them were probably when they started to
come out used I would buy them used
because I'm not an [__]
um well you well I I'll tell you right
now I probably haven't watched at least
a half of those I'll tell you the
problem with used
there's you know you first of all you
you can inspect the disk and everything
but sometimes you get a bad disc and
invisibly it's not you're not able to
but this is the re and I keep a lot of
DVDs because I like I I have VHS I
sometimes I like the texture of a
certain medium versus another fair but
one of the reasons I have been replacing
or upgrading movies that I really love
is because with the modern TVs a lot of
older DVDs you put them on and it's like
a picture in the center of the screen
and you can't adjust that yeah and
you're like this is just like it's not
formatted for modern television yeah you
know so what about the stream because I
own like 300 movies now on iTunes
because I feel like it's so easy right
to just click it it's always 9.99 12.99
I'm doing pretty well financially so I
just yeah
I've bought movies on iTunes that I have
on DVD upstairs because I didn't want to
go upstairs I've done that many times
yeah yeah Goldman had a great joke about
that he's like if I can throw this into
the DVD player I won't buy it something
like that you guys and Pete Holmes are
the only people I know that he'd said
that to me before well since he's rented
it on I've done it multiple times
doesn't feel like walking into the other
I've done it multiple times I won't pay
I won't pay above market value I'll if
it's a good deal like I always get I
always get stuck during the holidays
like I was like let's watch a Christmas
movie I'm like all right well home alone
is only 3.99 I'm not gonna go up the
steps exactly well I also only have one
cable so I have to unplug the the Apple
TV cable and plug in the DVD cable why
well I have there's two hdmis one has
cable like television well your TV only
has two HDMI ports I think so what is it
like a vintage
do we have like five I don't know
there's a couple on the back of that
thing that you don't know are there
I've been unplugging you only have two
ports on the side yeah that has other
ports back ports yeah back ports is it
mounted or on the on a it's on a console
thing yeah okay so you have access to
the back sure so you would know if
there's extras there's no extra I don't
think he's ever left I mean I paid I
like I palmed a guy to set it up to put
it on the stand I'm not very uh put it
on the stand yeah and that guy was in
the house hanging pictures I brought in
a guy to like hang pictures and put on
the stand I gotta tell you man I first
you were the one of the only guys I know
where I am not surprised you don't know
how many ports are on the back of that
TV well later on I
on my own
I'm talking to the TV
wires my brain gets my wires get crossed
it's all the wires I can't figure it out
I'm moving in like three weeks I'm
dreading it just because the wires just
upstairs
oh geez I know that's almost worse than
moving across like to another state I
know your lines are crossing it's so
much
it's so Within Reach upstairs but it's
still going to be a pain in the ass I
know someone just said that to be like
if you're moving across the country
upstairs it's still the same yeah yeah
that's true so when you when you invite
someone for plans to watch one of these
movies do you say when you invite them
that it's it that it's this 4K transfer
is that part of the part of the do you
want that them to know that no so then
they'd come to your house not knowing
that they're getting a four I have been
in my home with perhaps a date where we
say we're gonna go watch a movie and it
does feel very good to say
knock yourself out go you go over there
you pick something out right and they go
over and they go oh my God and they
weren't expecting that resolution that's
what they say it's so big they weren't
expecting the resolution what the screen
how big is the screen you send them to
the collection oh the collection oh they
get to peruse like it's a DVD Library
yeah yeah and then I made a joke I said
it so you got it I got that uh like
genitals yeah do you do out do
alphabetize or are they just or just
categorize I alphabetize I grouped
letters no no I group by letter
I don't alphabetize within the letters
it's too it's too much to keep up with
yeah but then this is one of the crazy
things I do I have a lot of movies that
I bought from one
uh specific label like like there are
restoration labels like so Arrow videos
are label where they get they they
cultivate old horror and genre movies
and then they restore them and do
special edition releases so like all my
arrows are in one place all my
criterions are in one place like you
know so that's that's a little more for
me than for them okay you know what I
mean yeah absolutely but I do a little
for me a little for them yeah we used to
collect vhs's like my dad did and then I
did I was into movie collecting so
before the DVDs I had hundreds and
hundreds of VHS and that was a that was
a real
kick in the end nuts because I had to
put them in those big Ikea bags you know
those blue Ikea bags they're like a buck
but you could put like 100 pounds in it
yeah I feel like five or six of those up
and brought them down to the Salvation
Army just dropped them there
I would have purchased those from you
some of them do you have VHS also a very
limited amount because New York is so
tight but one of the things so it's one
you feel when you're feeling like you
want the absolute worst resolution no it
looks dude it you gotta understand you
watch like a a horror movie from the 80s
on a VHS tape and it's the texture of
that the authenticity it looks awesome
it's a very uh the diverse military
what's the word I'm looking for very
similitude no idea the authenticity one
of the things I dream about when I own a
house they're a similitude no no that
sounds like a radio team I don't know
what that means
yeah
is it very no not not versus mojito very
similitude uh v-e-r-s-i
I
was one word
yeah there it is
just go to the definition
this is some thrilling radio here change
or being true or real I don't know the
details of the novel look go to uh
synonyms let's see that
I'm really I'm sorry I'm putting you to
work here
uh realism authenticity color
authenticity authenticity
I'm not convinced you use that word
correctly but sure I get what you were
getting I'm fully convinced I get what
you're getting too what's up guys let's
talk about game time game time game time
is an app that you can get and it is the
fast and easy way to buy tickets for
your sports your music comedy and
theater last minute you don't have to
stress anymore about months before they
guarantee their prices you can see the
angle of the stage or wherever the
performance is from your seat so you
know exactly what you're getting they
have a low price guarantee uh event
cancel protection uh and here's what
they do if you find a ticket that is
cheaper than the ticket they have in the
same rowing section they will refund you
110 of the difference yes absolutely
Flash Deals on last minute tickets I
mean it's just it's it's an awesome
awesome awesome service so here's what
we want we want you to do we want you to
forget the planning the months in
advance we want you to go get the deals
on tickets right up to the day of the
event by using Game Time snag the
tickets without the stress with Game
Time download the game time app create
an account and use code taste buds for
twenty dollars off your first purchase
terms apply again create an account and
redeem code taste buds for twenty
dollars off download game time today
last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed guys let's talk about prize
picks price picks is the largest
independently owned daily fantasy sports
platform in North America DFS that's
right uh they are the easiest and most
exciting way to play daily fantasy
sports it's just you against the numbers
so instead of battling thousands of
other players including pros and sharks
you pick more than or less than on a two
to six player stat projections and watch
the winnings roll in so they're
redefining how you play daily fantasy
sports and I like that because this is I
I don't understand Sports and I could
actually do you understand the numbers
yeah yeah and I I actually don't gamble
much the only thing I really gamble on
is football and I played fantasy
football for 26 years and I tried this
app out and I it was I was looking I
thought I was going to be intimidated it
was so simple to on understand it was
like fun to do I also like that they
have quick withdrawals easy gameplay and
an enormous selection of players and
Stat types and that's what makes price
picks the number one daily fantasy
sports app again this is like accessible
to everybody yeah I understand what that
means you know what I mean and it
doesn't intimidate me they do make it
fun like they offer weekly promotions
that can lead to like big payouts like
they do a taco Tuesday every Tuesday
price picks discounts select player
projections up to 25 to provide even
more value it's it's fun if you have any
interest check it out um go to
prizepix.com tastebuds and use the code
tastebuds for a first deposit match up
to a hundred dollars okay that's
prizepix.com taste buds and use the code
taste buds for a first deposit match up
to 100 daily fantasy sports Made Easy
prize picks folks Joe DeRosa here I am
hitting the big open road this fall with
I Never Promised You a Rose Garden the
tour coming to a bunch of cities
bunch of shows excited to see out there
September 16th Avenal New Jersey
September 21st through the 23rd Toronto
uh September 29th through October 1st
I'll be at skank Fest not doing the hour
there but I'll be there and I hope to
see you uh November 11th Philadelphia
Pennsylvania theater of the Living Arts
November 17th Pittsburgh PA November
18th Buffalo New York November 30th
Denver Colorado December 1st Phoenix
Arizona December 3rd Salt Lake City my
gosh my gosh my gosh we have so much
going on make sure you cop that new
salsa windfall album artificial birth
available on all streaming platforms now
we hope to see you people and I hope I
also I also hope to see you Joey roses
where you said in New York Joey roses
joeyroses.com we're open seven days a
week I'll see you there and that's where
the After parties happen on October 28th
what's up everybody I am on the road
right now just announced a lot of dates
for my tour they're on sale right now
you can get tickets at salvolcano
comedy.com I'm coming to Bowling Green
Cincinnati Toledo Wilkes-Barre
Wilmington making Savannah and Athens
Georgia uh I'm coming to Peoria Rockford
and Springfield Illinois Cedar Rapids
Duluth Appleton Rochester Davenport and
Elkhart Indiana gearing up to film my
special in Chicago uh in December tune
in next week I will give all the
information about this special taping
but until then Savile County comedy.com
and I'll see you guys on the road you
know sometimes you want a a an older uh
medium
yeah it's not funny the way you tell the
story is funny sometimes you want an
older medium here's why and uh special
effects guys we'll talk about this they
say
the Grain and the Darkness and texture
of older film and stuff like that it hit
a lot of stuff
so that's why sometimes you watch like
an older horror movie on like there was
a second jewelry or whatever and you go
like this looks so corny and it's
because yeah because the clarity is too
sharp okay so there's different there's
different ways to enjoy things anyway
wait but we gotta we gotta but before we
get to the pizza battle please we got to
talk about the ice cream thing that Joe
posed
what remember the ice cream question
here oh yeah
save it for the air yes yes yes yes so
he went blank you see how blank he just
went well I know I think I felt like the
the conversation hadn't ended on its own
volition the DVD it was erupt it was
abrupt it hadn't but I'm scared
synapse didn't connect with the ice
creams when you said what about the ice
cream I feel bad that I sidetracked us
to this extent how bad do you feel scale
of one to ten eight whoa yeah because
that's really crazy I feel like I was
talking about myself and my own
interests and I didn't mean to do that I
would go higher than a two on that yeah
you could beat yourself up two's a
little tough yeah I've told people I
hate them to their face and was below
eight I was one of them
much uh more uh
just tougher fair I just mean in in
relevance to this particular I just want
to proceed what you feel no I don't feel
bad like like it's not an eight like if
I hurt your feelings and I was at an
eight it'd be a different kind of eight
okay I'm at an eight four as bad as you
can feel about talking about your DVDs
inside of conversations you're having a
hard time understanding scales I'm
trying to talk about the very
familiarity of how bad I feel uh what
the word definitely use that wrong what
was the word there is milditude no it
said the authenticity very similitude
It also says color color is also a
synonym it's wild and I say I'm laying
out in the sun I'm trying to get a
little Varys Miller dude I don't know I
always just thought of as something that
was like wholly authentic incredibly
authentic that's what I I thought okay
fair enough depicting yeah depicting
realism as in art or literature but I
think it means like the execution of the
story not well that said very similar
yes
all right I got I did it okay on the
SATs with the English I scored so long
as it is it's insane how low
I don't think I ever cracked a thousand
oh that's not that bad
ouch I did 650 math
but my but my verbal was not good my
verbal was like 490 or 5 10 or something
like that I think I did a cumulative 980
or so that's good it was ready was it 10
50. 10.50 hi folks 10.50 I mean what's
650.
1040. so you're up you got me by 10
points no are you kidding is it
490 is
10 40 11 40. what is it
no 650 and 490
sometimes I think I cracked 11 but I
don't think I ever did
and when the times that I do the times
you do Sunday cracks 11. yeah
yeah not even a thousand numbers
I didn't prep at all for it I winged it
both times the second time I think I
cracked 900 I was like good enough I'm
out of here I'm not doing this I had I
had no interest in going to college I
knew I wasn't going and then I was also
an athlete these people at home might
not believe it but I I missed the day of
uh track that's right uh I missed the
day you seem like a track star oh yeah
look at these yeah Gams
um I missed the day of the test taking
and then so I had to do it on my own and
I did it during school hours they don't
allow for that I swear to God you have
some kind of connections no by myself
how did they let you take it on your own
you should have just been not allowed in
college I didn't go to college I didn't
even apply to a college that's why I
didn't care and I said why'd you take it
a 10 50 because you're required to
you're not required I what are they
going to do to you that's an excellent
question I don't know I didn't have
these abilities to push back as a boy
okay I was like okay I gotta take it but
anyways the point of the story if I may
yes please I'm a guest I was they caught
me spinning in my chair because I didn't
give a [__] I was spinning and then I
looked over my guidance counselor was
like looking through the little window
and the thing I was like Costanza in
there
I still got a 1050. it's in my pocket
right here where's your food on this all
right guys sandwiches
wait so you posted an ice cream question
post a nice good question I go to
Sundays and Cones over here I'll throw a
plug out for these folks you guys know
Sundays and Cones nope oh man 10th
Street and Third Avenue right beautiful
best ice cream in the city in my
personal opinion
I've acquired a daily allergy a dairy
allergy which has really prevented my
ice cream Ventures lately it's a bummer
but I do love ice cream so I got great
cookies over there too okay what's it
called again
Sundays and I think I'm right on the
address I believe it's 10th Street and
Third Avenue okay and uh great place
and you uh you posed the question I went
there I get two I'm a chocolate chip guy
I get two scoops of chocolate chip and I
was with our mutual friend no vanilla
okay vanilla chocolate chip and I get
two scoops I was with our mutual friend
Ari shaffir and he thought that was
bananas to get two of the same flavor he
gets two different flavors I'd never
heard of that well he never heard of me
I mean I've heard of I know this
Cosmopolitan or whatever it's called
with strawberries Neapolitan yes sir
with the three players so I've seen
three flavors chocolate Vanilla swirl of
course but I've never seen someone get
me a a scoop of chocolate here's what I
would say I think you and this is
interesting they're arguing on a cone or
even in a cup I'm I'm cup I'm a cup man
oh so you never heard of two different
Scoops in a cup no two different scoops
on a cone is a little bit more first of
all I can't tell you the last time
I mean I haven't had ice cream in a cone
in a long time but even when I still was
in my ice cream cone days
I can't tell you the last time I had
hard ice cream in a cone like scooped I
can't remember the last time I had a
comb where it wasn't soft serve oh why
you're missing out I don't know did you
say it are you saying that though like
it's a good thing or a bad thing I'm
just saying I can't remember the last
time I went to a place that actually was
scooping ice cream like most places it
was like a that was so funny about this
goop is funny listen I just say scoop
I'm laughing I think you and Ari are
equally crazy in this argument because
that's just like shaffir to go it's
ridiculous not to get tooth no it's not
already shut up well he's very critical
and he's very critical he's not
mentioned you know what he said to me
once I brought a friend out with us and
he goes yeah they weren't as annoying as
your friends usually are there's
something wrong with Ari let's get you
know let's just get that out of the
table uh you know what was he referring
to an annoying friend no okay no no he
just says he says inappropriate things
uh but my point I've done very critical
is what I'm saying yes Joy you just said
so he's nuts for saying to only get two
different flavors is the only way but I
also think it's a little crazy that you
never thought of the option getting two
different flavors well my thing is I
like this one this is the flavor I'm
Desiring give me a large you don't go to
and this is a bad example but you're not
like give me a large half Coke half
Sprite I understand they mix a little
bit but you get a large Coke I
understand you're not like give me half
if you only want one and then there's
your answer right there it's a closed
chapter there's not even anything to
discuss right but if you feel like you
have the hankering for more than one or
you can't choose
I don't have a haircut I would say in my
scoop days I probably went same flavor
more than anything because I I came up
in a time they didn't have all these
goddamn flavors it was chocolate vanilla
and strawberry at wallaby farms and my
dad would take me to the counter and
he'd say what kind do you want do you
want one scoop or two and I would get
two scoops of chocolate usually yeah
that was usually the goddamus ice cream
yourself a Lactaid pill pop that eat
your ice it's not a lactose intelligence
it's a dairy allergy so I get Ben and
the problem is is I get I know you get
the non-dairy you get the non-dairy
that's let me tell you something that's
no the Ben and Jerry's non-dairy is
awesome you got those in Montauk and you
left them there and I tasted one of them
I threw it out immediately because it
was two it's so many calories dude I
just was like I can't eat all of this so
you bought four pints and then Donita
because the calories two pints and I ate
most of both of them
but if you want to exaggerate all day
with me I'll exaggerate all day in my
earlier ice cream days I was the same
but once I opened my eyes to the fact
first of all I don't just do it just to
do it if there's two I want I'll
entertain it otherwise I'm still on your
team right but as I was saying before
the cameras are on and this is a little
behind the scenes look is that my big uh
my big concern with the two scoops is
that when they bleed together is it
going to be greater is it gonna is it
gonna cause like you know something to
be off in in the whole thing and often
what happens is you realize the second
the first flavor is so good you're
having a great time you're moving along
and then you get to the second flavor
and you're like [__] I don't like this I
wish I had that off I do agree when it's
too well not in a bowl that's never an
issue if you can't manage your Scoops in
a bowl I mean I don't know what to talk
to you about over here what are we
talking about you're in control on a
cone you got a stacked situation going
and then that's a problem but does not
ice cream drip into the lower scoop it
drips
I would get your argument if you're
talking cone I see I don't care for a
cone the cone it can it can topple over
it melts down your arm I never
understood in fact I've never eaten ice
cream on a cone ever in my whole life
it's like an ice cream man named cone
you
um you're missing out and I'll tell you
why because it's not that big of a a
puzzle to solve uh you know it's it just
don't eat it like on the equator and
just eat it with efficiency have a
napkin at the bottom you keep
maintenance on the side here and I
wanted to make it when you get to a
point where the ice cream can't drip no
more then you feel really in control and
then you can eat at your own pace and I
got to tell you that I disagree with you
I don't mean a sugar cone I mean a
waffle cone the bottom of that cone that
last bite with everything down there
it's a treat that you've never
experienced that's a shame I don't like
crunchy
I'm a good crunch all facets not even
ice cream I disagree with you I think a
cone with two different flavors is a lot
more work than you're than you're saying
it is right now I I do get the work part
of it you know you lick it and then
it's just insane
kid can't wrap his head around two
different flavors in a bowl but I think
the more often you see the image of two
different ice creams on a cone like in a
cartoon you see a green green and a blue
or whatever not blue that's crazy no
they have Cookie Monster now ice cream
I've seen it there you go yeah dry land
is not a mess I've seen it well that's
ridiculous now this guy let's talk to
him because this guy we all have a
problem with this guy
well he's the world record he's Guinness
record that's that's all
um
all right so hard or soft
I'm hard I'm hard too currently I I went
uh when I was introduced to soft serve
nothing was ever going to throw me off
that again but then when I got older I
started to reappreciate hard yeah I mean
you could put it on that way I like soft
yeah you put a gun to my head I'm hard
I'd rap
I would rather have hard I would either
have scoop Now That I'm Older yeah
soft also has
there is a chemical thing that happens
with soft that's kind of weird like it's
like soft doesn't taste real all the
time it's now very small to that you
know what I mean but you know what I
mean like soft you're like they did this
is this isn't natural well soft is fun
to lick the lick is fun yeah yeah and
it's very easy to maintain let me ask
you at home when you're scooping when
you're self scooping at home do you
leave it out let it soften or do you
just work work it and get in there no no
I let it sit for a little while and then
all the fun it's like making a cup of
tea and then do you do you skim the
sides first where it's the the softest
yeah I kind of go the softest and then
at some point I'm eating out of the
container yeah and then at some point
I'll flip it and get to the bottom
when I eat out of the container I eat
and concentric circles inward
oh yeah I do that yeah I do that I do
that I uh I might get a whole thing of
ice cream after this not dairy of course
man I'm really thinking about it now
yeah you got to go Sundays and Cones
great great place yeah
I'm not so sure they have uh like
gluten-free or sugar-free it's all the
same that [__] the gluten the fructose
the dairy I can't keep track of these
people with their bro see it's really
easy they used to charge for all those
yeah and you know what's a mind-boggling
it's easy to find dairy free and it's
easy to find sugar-free but it's very
hard to find both
combined I like peas but I hate pea soup
what's that from that's iPhone of course
it is what episode is that that's when
they're the lip reader when's Gwen's
reading lips and she's leading the lips
and he says I like peas but I hate pea
soup and I hate carrots but
and that creamer goes me too we lost uh
we lost uh video here all right let's go
let's get into the battle okay which is
a lightning kind of round We're Not
Gonna time them but we have three
battles within the within the umbrella
of pizza you have three lightning rounds
here I chose these will not count
towards wins or losses for either you or
me because I have chose chosen to sit
out of these battles I'm good at
partaking the battles but I said I can't
pick a side this is the first time it's
ever happened to me I couldn't pick a
side in either one I was like it's too
case to case for me
but I've got a lot to say Okay so we're
just gonna have fun today okay all right
all right Joe all right the last week of
school what do I do when like the rules
don't apply we're gonna battle Yeah it
feels like you're playing with a kid and
he's like I can fly there's no wins or
losses we can all and you're just kind
of like you're gonna get a participation
trophy today yeah yeah well first things
we're doing um are we doing extra sauce
versus extra cheese yep okay and I will
tell you I'm in your camp Oh wait we got
to start the Oh okay that's okay ready
yes time two
b-a-t-t-l-e Buzz you're almost there I
caught it on the last part yeah all
right versus extra cheese Go For It Go
For It Go For It folks let's talk about
bird dogs and I'm not talking about this
day
oh
bird dogs are short no bird dogs and
again when I say short I'm not talking
about this dead
it's all line of clothes I have tons of
shorts I have joggers I have pants I
have shirts they're awesome they they
feel like they're gym shorts but they
look like they're really nice upscale
shorts and that's what you need if you
know me that's what I want I want a
Leisure where I want to look like I'm
dressed up and I want to feel like I'm
in bed I like that it's a it's a it's a
it's a piece of clothing that hustles
the other person you thought I had nice
shorts on but they're gym shorts and
they thought they were khaki you know
when you like like like you have a belt
on or something you come home and you
take them off and you put on sweats yeah
and it's like all right now I just feel
it just feels good that's like they they
fit because they stretch yeah to
wherever your bird dogs made things that
look like khakis they feel like you're
in the sweats the whole time I love it
man uh they're comfortable as [__] and
that is coming straight from the bird
dog's mouth uh please go to birddogs.com
taste buds and enter promo code taste
buds for a free tumbler with your order
that's bird
dogs.com slash taste buds I'm gonna say
it again
birddogs.com taste buds and use promo
code taste buds for a free tumbler and
by the way I have the tumbler and I love
it I'm not just saying that it's good
the top seals keep stuff hot and cold
for like eight hours and it fits in the
cup holder in the car so I'm just saying
I like the Tumblr
all right last one uh you know there's
already extra cheese on a regular slice
Imo
the amount of cheese on a regular slice
of original cheese pizza is a lot of
cheese
I'm already there I don't need more
cheese on top of that cheese I always
had a problem with stuffed crust
okay yeah
I'm just saying yeah I'm not disagreeing
with you no no I could see I haven't had
stuff across much is that just the Pizza
Hut specific thing well some I think a
couple places Seinfeld a great bit when
he went he went the whole goddamn thing
is cheese
uh go ahead I think that's a myth that
stuffed crust I don't think it ever
existed Pizza Hut still I think he's
pushing oh well Pizza Hut yeah but but
anyway I'm sorry go ahead now well first
of all uh one thing I hate too is
opening a box of pizza and there's just
oil everywhere and the oil is produced
well from the sauce and the cheese but
the oil is horrible and then you know
the oil if you're holding it you got a
lot of times I'll blot it and drip it
out if you don't it hits the back way
you're ruining pants you do a drip you
do a drip if it's in the box and the Box
isn't corrugated cardboard that's going
right through that box that's staining
anything you got that on the surface
there's a log Game Hollywood film it
takes bed store slice and puts his
grease on this yeah rain dance that's
the best part yeah
great film I also think you go live by
the way if I'm sorry I don't mean I'm
feeling too verbose
no problem because you didn't have a lot
of opinions on this but I do yeah I do
think the grease are blotted off but I
do think the Greece is the sign of a
good slice because you're getting you
know that cheese is gonna taste really
good when you get that oil grease is
coming out yeah I somebody Cooks a pizza
and the cheese is just white and none of
that grease comes out I'm like get the
[__] out of here which we're gonna get
to it that grease could be a weapon of
mass destruction if the people that they
were using it on care about stains and
clothes because I have never seen that
grease fall on a piece of a tactile
piece of clothing and I've never seen
that Grease come out ever gotcha no have
you ever I don't care what store dry
cleaning you got to go to dry cleaning
and it comes out I've done it yeah I've
got it I've gotten it out via dry
cleaning many times but now you're
paying eight dollars because you may
just one moment you know one moment
you're off with a slice of pizza and
you're like I wear the pants for 45
minutes God damn it eight dollars is the
price of a large original cheese pie
when I delivered that's wild wow that's
wild so the greatest extra sauce or
extra cheese I I I'm I'm case to case
look some places don't use enough sauce
and I go extra sauce some places don't
use enough cheese I go extra cheese no
no no no no don't don't don't don't
don't don't approach it as you're
solving a problem the slice is already
fine you want extra of something
I never want extra of either if the
slice is made properly ever okay ever
ever ever ever ever if the slice is not
made pro or the pie is not made properly
I love it's a I know it's not the best
pizza in the world but it's a guilty
pleasure I love Pizza Hut pizza I love
it I love Domino's
they don't put enough sauce on pizza you
have to ask for extra sauce but it
doesn't need extra cheese it needs extra
sauce but that's not because I want
extra sauce it just doesn't have enough
sauce on it people love extra well extra
cheese is a normal order that's a big
popular order extra cheese no one you
ever hear I never hear anyone order
extra sauce I'm all extra sauce on
everything chicken parm rigatoni pizza
but I think some places do the sauce
like this they do the circles and then
it leaves empty spots I want it covered
now I gotta tell you when it comes to a
deep dish pizza
Chicago style or Grandma Pizza I'm not
against the extra layer of sauce it's a
different experience but that's not what
we mean right
that's not what we're saying no you're
not sauce in every bite and often you
get to the towards the crust and it's
there's no sauce sometimes in the middle
there's no sauce I want sauce across I'm
a saucy guy
I'll tell you something else I'll tell
you something else and this is why I
think it's really important first of all
you're throwing the proportions off when
you when you're getting the extra cheese
it's a sloppy eat it's still fun
Everyone likes cheese but here's the
thing
there's plenty of companies that make a
very good
mozzarella right so the shredded cheese
that's going on top a lot of a lot of
places because pizzerias they order
those from other places right and if
it's good it's good if it tastes good it
tastes the same all across the board the
secret to a good pizza is the secret to
it's the recipe of the sauce I mean you
need everything to come together but the
sauce is up to the individual pizza
maker they make the sauce but you could
have 20 great pizzerias that use the
same cheese so if the sauce is good
if you're in one specific area their
chances are very high that you're
getting the same cheese on yeah like you
know but if it's serviceable
the sauce also is ordered I mean you
know really
it depends on it depends but I mean you
know sauce in a lot of places is going
to be like their salad look dude the
average Pizzeria if you think they're
they're they're you know their their
grandmother's in the back doing a Sunday
gravy no I just think an employee Joe
just an employee I'm just I'm just
speaking colorfully okay it doesn't you
know we don't need that what I'm just
having a colorful time I yeah you're
having a very verse military listen to
me I'm saying yeah dude I think they're
getting a Vata I think I think most
pizzerias make their own sauce I would
disagree I think they're getting cans of
salt because I've worked the pizzerias
where you have the Kansas sauce you open
they come off the truck with the Cisco
stuff
the sauce to make the sauce though
no those cans are made sauce already and
they're I don't know I I I I think some
places do it and and some places don't
you know what I mean there are plenty of
places that do not make such a sauce
makes the sauce you lift his feet get
blood to his head let his head give
birth to his feet
yeah sure
really oh for for the yeah okay all
right so um so let's go let's go to well
it's just the first battle it's just the
first battle yeah all right so we're
doing a lightning Round Here we know
where we stand we've said enough on this
topic we've got a few thousand votes in
already extra sauce extra cheese let's
get that Humble Pie segment in here wow
I didn't think you'd choose that pimp
wow okay clobbered I gotta be honest
though clobbered extra cheese
point two percent for extra cheese well
to me though anytime with you anytime a
pizza is bad or I don't like it it's
usually because there's not enough sauce
oh the sauce is very Bland I want a
spicy sauce a zesty sauce I want extra
sauce lots of sauce I'm never like oh
the cheese are you very well disgusting
I would agree well done very well done I
want to agree with you and I wish I wish
I'd kind of taken a side now but I
didn't but I would agree with you that
more it doesn't happen frequently but
more frequently than me needing extra
cheese I will say can I have a side of
sauce for the pizza and I'll I'll dunk
it yes I've had to do that more than
I've had to ask for extra cheese exactly
can I just throw this out that we didn't
discuss this just real quick how do you
feel about the big bubble some people
like the Bubba if there's a bubble on
the pizza I'm taking it back I'm
throwing it in the trash and I don't
even want to be friends with people that
like the bubble some people like the
bubble they really don't have a hard
take on it and the fact that you do is
interesting no you're in the rung you
should have a strong take on the bubble
the bubbles
in like the Arts and what now in the
Arts of the Arts yeah I don't really see
bubbles anymore on Pizza I don't know
maybe they Rectify another problem right
well I I mean I don't mind the bubble
because sometimes it's fun because it
gets crispy and then you bite it looks
like a little biodome on there and you
bite it and then you see like it's Airy
and crunchy yeah but there's no cheese
in the bubble see it's just a bit yeah I
think it's beautiful and it's
imperfection it's not wabi-sabi you're
incorrect also it's taking up where
there was should be cheese and sauce
what is our second uh lightning round it
is no versus no crust this is another
thing that many people love to say oh
it's the best part because I've never
eaten crust in my life listen let me say
this let me say this the only reason the
crust is is and I hate when people say
it's the best part thank you it's not
the best part it's the worst it's it's
an it's a it's crucial because I will
say the worst pizza I've ever had in my
life it started with bad crust it
started with the fact that they don't
know that's why Pizza
oh
yeah I hope that's clear for them
because we're not talking the crust
because the crust is in incredibly
important but we're talking do you eat
the crust at the end I usually I usually
I get to that edge I usually toss that
crust aside it's extra calories it's
taking up more space I've already eaten
something not great for me you're
describing the bubble you know yeah and
then I'm also like it's just bread
without any of the good stuff on it now
Pizza Hut once again brilliant they go
we're gonna take our crust we're gonna
put cheese on it and we're gonna call it
breadsticks and I was like you guys are
really sharp well the reason I disagree
is because I because it I won't eat the
crust on a crappy slice but I I like to
think that I frequent places that are
you know really above board when it
comes to Pizzeria really with the clam
pizzas even even
pizza so many people have come to me
since that episode and been like what
are they talking so many have come to me
and said Sal is a lunatic it's not a
thing that exists anywhere but it is but
it's not in one in one specific region
yeah in your neighborhood Island yes it
exists yeah I mean literally the
equivalent of me going my Aunt Sammy is
everywhere it's a population you're a
fan it's a population of 550 000 people
huh that's that there's white available
white clamp is available to all of us I
don't know if we have a calculator but
there's like 375 million people in the
country but I'm saying
literally it's prolific it's it's it's
where you're from
yeah like 10 minutes away yeah but
that's one place out of an entire
country
if you if you if we got some type of
accurate number
analytics you do remember we called
three Staten Island places and two of
them did not have it you do remember
that we used to call them uh new city
places no we called Staten Island we
went into Staten Island just to make it
but you heard of it
he said he's never heard of it I think
no I think I had heard I don't know I
would have to go back to the episode I
mean pause yeah
but the pressure no Crush it's a waste
it's a waste the pizza is good pizza
then the crust is amazing all the way
through I don't guide CrossFit is nice
and charred it's got a little bit of the
the uh the the flower on the bottom the
uh some people put a little cornmeal on
there it's crunchy can I tell you I hate
that salmonella whatever that [__] is
that they put up semolina semolina I
can't salmonellas sorry for all the I
also don't care for someone uh I can't
stand it I will call a place and say can
you not put that [__] on my pizza please
and then the guy doesn't understand
because he's some genzo from across the
pond hey
oh but no but but like they're always a
lot
no there's no way to get it off I'm like
I don't understand you got it all I'd
get it off I don't care for the stigma
that I still have everyone calls me a
child you're a little girl you suck
you're bad at comedy all because I like
to have a pile of crust at the end and
then I have to secretly wrap it in a
towel and hide it or shift it because
people are like you're a dork you suck
you don't eat the crust but I'm like
it's it's lacking the Main Ingredients
the cheese and the sauce but if it's a
really crispy beautiful delicious crust
especially on a thin a thin pizza I'll
tell you what I've done sometimes
two or three slices I've eaten two no no
like a thin like what you would call
thin crust where it's like Cracker thin
that crust doesn't count you eat that
because it's it's almost non-existent I
agree my favorite that's non-existent
I'm talking about crust but I'm also not
talking about the doughy white ones that
are undercooked that are disgusting no I
know you know we're still talking about
a good piece you feel like you don't
need to dip that question or anything
I I'll tell you what else I've done I've
eaten the two three slices two or three
says saved all three crusts then ate the
crust in succession at the end what I
like to do I'm very giving I save my
crust and I give them to whoever like
someone that might like the crust I say
here here's a little treat it's like
giving dog bones to a puppet
that is so disgusting to me that the
other person eats it not you that
another person eats it that literally
would be like if you handed me a hot
wing boned and you're like here you go
if you want the meat left on this today
I'm making out with you your mouth was
right up against that crust it was in
your mouth I don't mind mouth I'll kiss
mostly on the lips you're not but you're
not the one eating it but even if
someone I mean I guess if someone ate
half a hot dog and gave it to me I
probably wouldn't be thrilled that's why
it's the same thing it's different I
know but I'm not the one either as he's
pointed out I'm not doing anything the
crust but I'm not saying my wife eats my
crust and we uh well have made out yeah
yeah it's your wife's a different a
little bit of different story yeah yeah
but but I will say this sometimes I love
the crust but it has to be Pizza Hut or
a place that like where the crust tastes
like garlic bread or something almost in
and of itself then I'm like now it's
another part of the meal
but now what what crosses garlic bread I
don't know okay it's like a butter well
you know I don't think you're playing on
a Level Playing Field when you mentioned
Pizza I think they're just I think
they're playing fast and loose with
pizza rolls and I think that you're
applying it to to the standard I maybe
could have took taken aside in the crush
no Crush battle I probably should have
what do you think about the stigma if
someone comes to your home I go to your
house it's a Super Bowl party whatever
I'm eating pizza I leave the cookies are
you judging I mean are you guys upset
with me do you think I'm gonna ask no
and the stigma bothers me because it's
like the stigma of being a single guy in
your 40s that you get from married
people yeah where they're like well
that's weird why are you still singing a
little creepy but so that you think
that's taking a side with you here I
know I appreciate it why are you still
single why are you married you weirdo I
don't know I like someone someone will
eat my pizza crust that's why for
clarification you think that is the same
as the stigma with crust I think I do
agree that there are certain double
standards in this Society we live in you
know a living in a society yeah yeah
there are certain double scams in the
society that are so imbalanced yeah it
makes me angry and I do think that two
of them
are the married person judging The
Bachelor and the pizza question yeah but
he's right people like I would never
judge you for eating the crust but if I
don't need it but somebody goes oh you
don't need to cry I don't even know what
you're talking about why would anyone
what what problem could anyone have if
they were with you and it was their
people know why you don't know you have
to cry you know why you don't know what
we're talking about why because you eat
the crust you're on the other side baby
yeah Fair
grounds is that
[Music]
dial this eating something you don't
want to eat because your parents are
making you you're my parents right not
you these people so somebody literally
you've had this happening where someone
like uh like like like every chastises
you for every day every day hating Crush
should be a component for diagnosing
mental illness exactly see they call me
mentally ill I'm not mental there's a
whole oh there's a whole new people out
there if you don't like pizza crust
you're a serial killer there you go wow
I'm sorry I had no idea you were dealing
with yes if you're an adult leaving
Pizza bones you're the problem with
Society the crust is the best part
of ticks talking about my whole life
they make me sit on the back of the bus
these people wait wait scroll a little
bit more would that take the Rosa make
sure to eat every Oh I thought that's
something
I thought so too all right that's easy
what do we got here
I mean clearly I think it's going to be
uh what's going to be a Whopper you
think it's going to be 90 10.
they don't know what I've been I think
it'll be another 70 something I think it
takes 86 14. okay called it pimpy whoa
what is it 84.8 wow that's pretty close
15.2 uh I gotta say that's probably in
one of the top 10 biggest lopsided
battles we've we've seen 5 000 votes I
knew it was going to be the crust that's
a that's a it's a certain kind of
psychopath that's like why aren't you
eating this thing and I'm like it's it's
the bones of the pizza yeah it's a
totally different thing I think I I have
a feeling this next one tonight's gonna
be a good night today is your day bro I
have a feeling that this next one is
going to also be these people
psychotically
who are forward for margarita pizza
no Margarita is going to Margarita
better thing and Al here the only the
only answer here is original cheese I
don't think it's going to this is this
is now this really is really good this
is something that I'm laying in bed
think about I'm having a child in six
weeks I'm not even thinking about that
I'm thinking about Margarita Pizza
slowly pushing out cheese and the the
people acting like this is
interchangeable many comedy clubs even
have this I'm not gonna name names one
Manhattan comedy club that I frequent
you asked for a cheese pizza they
literally will go you got it and they
bring out a margarita pizza and it's one
of the the grossest lies ever portrayed
on the American people betrayed's not
the right I uh I agree that uh it's it's
margarita pizza has become
the Texas Hold'em of foods nobody knew
what the hell Texas Holdem was until
celebrity poker came out on TV
well that was the same time it was like
all these poker things came out and all
of a sudden everybody was like oh so you
we have a game we play Texas Hold'em
It's like because you saw it in a movie
or you saw a Vince Vaughn playing it on
on IFC or whatever the hell that show
was on in another movie you saw Vince
Vaughn eating the Margarita Pizza you
know but this is it like he is right
like Margaret I don't I don't hate
margarita pizza but this has become a
thing when I go to a pizza place I will
always try the margarita slice I am
curious but this is a thing where it has
become like this it's not it's not even
that it's it's because that people like
it it's the odd the arrogance of people
that the thing they found out about a
few years ago they're like well if you
don't like it you're addicted it's like
shut up shut up couldn't agree more and
then we're hanging out with I've already
looked at some of the comments that's
these are the comments you're out there
in your s-i bubble you don't know what
it's like man yeah
I'm getting eggs thrown at me and banana
peels and I'm walking around that's that
I have the same exact rep it's not that
I'm against margarita pizza but
sometimes when you want a Classic Slice
it's not Margarita and a lot of places
have Margarita and they don't and it's
like you ever order and it comes and
it's not an original cheese and you were
like why didn't you specify that this
was not going to be a classic pizza
that's what I'm saying also I don't want
tomatoes on my pizza they squirt there's
seeds involved it's disgusting I've had
plenty of Margarita pizzas where it
wasn't where it was still just regular
old sauce but then you get the discs of
cheese I mean that's annoying because
you could never if you if you bite into
a disc the whole distance the whole
thing you can have to use your fingers
and that's that's nature look at this
look at this people have horrible taste
in Pizza picking cheese over Margarita
people have horrible taste in Pizza
picking cheese people have horrible
taste in light bulbs picking Thomas
Edison oh it is the original form of the
food this is so nuts it's the most basic
kind and this is lately they're being
shits over the spelling because you
spelled it wrong oh did I yeah I did I
that autocorrected then everybody's
being a [__] over the spill no you no I
think they're saying what is margarita
pizza so no no several people you missed
it we're being like Oh I guess you mean
the drink because a margarita pizza
all right nothing beats fresh voting
don't think we're talking about
hold on let me address Genie let me
address Genie nothing beats fresh mutts
okay you know what else you know what
else nothing beats saying mozzarella
instead of mutts
so much I I can't say wait it's supposed
to be dude dude
dude it's on a sandwich no I also don't
like stupid people like you that don't
say the whole word wait I actually don't
know what's right people say mutts oh
they shorten it to Mush they shorten it
are you against mutts or mozzarella or
mozzarella
mozzarella she what she's writing is
much yeah but people go that's how
people say it now I don't say much but
do you have a problem with mozzarella
versus mozzarella I could do I could do
without the action we're in the United
States
I thought your original gripe was that
people say mozzarella instead of Mozart
I hate when people say much the word
much I don't like oh no I'm so sorry
it's the mutts yeah dude give me a give
me a sandwich refresh much what are you
doing
huh it makes me so I'm way worked up
from this yeah I like it I like I like a
little bit of the fever in here right
now Margarita is how it was originally
imagined regular pizza we know is a
product of commune shut up how do you
feel about it
you're a New Yorker how do you feel
about the ordering by saying let me get
her because I don't care for that I
don't like it I'm gonna get a uh scooply
Boop and a poppity pop how about you say
may I have a please can I tell you who
corrected me in that and it changed my
life oh I was with Marina Franklin
and I we were ordering some food
somewhere you're an ex let me get her
and I said I said let me get it and she
goes say please and I go
oh Jesus you're right it was like so
clear in one moment but I could see that
as like a vintage New York like Flavor
like hey let me get a lunch pie please
I don't see any disrespect I probably
have said let me get it but I probably
have also said may I please have but I
guess it's also tone right because you
can be like may I please have uh but uh
let me let you said it like let me get a
uh right but some people like let me get
a uh this I know
that's right let's go around and do do
do a nice version of let me get it in a
shitty version of it please yeah a nice
version of let me get a yeah and a
shitty version yeah yeah please all
right
hi
um let me get a uh a regular slice
please no no no what you said let me get
it yeah can I please okay hold on hold
on yeah all right
hey let me get a um cheese slice piece
please oh okay okay
let me try it again let me try it again
please
good afternoon right I can say that can
I say something before no no okay okay
ready ready got it watch right into it
yeah yeah
let me get a cheese slice please oh I
can't do it I can't do it it's hard yeah
all right
well this might be proof that you can't
do it nice let me get it all right ready
let me get a cheese slice
all right now do a shitty please yeah
I'll do a shitty okay please
all right
may I have a regular cheese slice please
yeah wow that's good yeah that was good
that was very good that was very nice
yeah all right ready yeah
see I don't care for that let me I don't
like to let me get no matter what I
think it's playful I think it's fun yeah
that's right nice and then uh and then
uh let me get a cheese slice
please
this is tough there's been so many good
ones out today that's hard to choose
this one you were supposed to say may I
please may I please because you still
said let me get up you're ready oh I got
a good one ready ready yeah may I please
have a cheese slice yeah but that's good
well I think now we're out of the
parameters of the spirit of the game
this is shitty no no you can shout at
anyone I love you okay ready ready I'll
do it don't you don't use your voice
watch out I won't shout may I please
heavy cheese slice I still think you're
cheating in the game that's not cheating
it's you should say it in a shitty way
that's a shitty way there's this evening
well I think this is implying that
there's been some incident beforehand it
implies that you've been trying to get a
slice first I will admit that mine
sounds like you're coming into the
middle of a scene yeah something
happened in here yeah it's been bad
service all day it sounds like you just
found out your property taxes went up
because that's the thing with let me get
it the only way to protect the to make
the let me get it acceptable is to do
here we go ready ready yeah
that's the counter okay
please uh G slice yes ignoring yeah on
the phone even all right let me again
may I please get a cheese oh very good
Joe very good that was good right very
good and then let me I'll try a nice let
me get it but I think it's impossible
let me get a
not bad yeah it's more of a you have to
make it inquisitive yeah not uh a demand
it's kind of like these people where you
say something and they go what's the
matter
yeah and you say well nothing's a matter
right I said that uh that's a pet peeve
yeah I'm just like upset what time is it
yeah I'm like what's the matter what
happened yeah oh I do that let's see I
hate it let's see who takes this one
all right let's uh Humble Pie segment
we're gonna wait wait did we go to the
oh we already did they were all right
all right all right let's go here
where's pimp going on this original
cheese drum roll
thank heaven nice thank you finally okay
some justice here yes no change is good
the original cheese is winning 70.4 to
the Margaritas 29.6 is that I didn't get
the H in there right on the margarita I
didn't get the eggs
Joe plug away please oh I have a new
special it's out right now I think when
does this come out it's out right now it
had a big weekend we're already at three
million views for God's sakes a new
special it's called enough for everybody
it's on YouTube it's free it's streaming
I have two others also on YouTube called
I hate myself in this year's material
three in three years how does he do it
who knows I was gonna say what are you
doing what about every eight weeks at
this point yeah at this point but uh I
swear to God it's good go check it out
watch it leave a comment that's awesome
buddy congrats genuinely that Joe list
is one of my favorite Comics oh he's
great he's so funny he's such an amazing
joke writer uh
his I appreciate it I just felt like
that was kind of uh watch this that
wasn't let me get up no thank you thank
you guys for having me I seriously I
love the show I'll come and just sit
here like the guy from the Tom Green
Show
yeah who is he now I don't know he's
laughing somewhere yeah but you guys
just tickled me sideways we love you
dude you're welcome anytime and we love
you still love you baby
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like Sue Fool's gonna fight but
only one food can be right taste buds
man yeah they're coming to them